DAVID WINER: Hi, my
name's David Winer.
I'm a product manager at Google
focused on the Kotlin language,
compiler, and libraries.
JAMES WARD: Hi, I'm
James Ward, a developer
advocate at Google Cloud, and
I've been doing a lot of Kotlin
lately.
DAVID WINER: And we're here to
talk today about what Kotlin is
and why it's a great
language for Cloud.
So let's get started.
First, we want to
give an overview
of what Kotlin looks like and
what some of its features are.
Kotlin is a JVM language,
so it looks a lot like Java
in some ways and uses a
lot of the same machinery
under the hood.
There are some cool kind of
differentiating features,
though.
The first is that nullability
is baked into the type
system in Kotlin, so this
question mark operator
that you see here
actually makes it
so the compiler
and tooling catches
a lot of the potential null
pointer exceptions you might
be used to seeing at runtime.
Kotlin also has first-class
support for lambdas
through this nice
trailing lambda syntax.
And functional programming
is a really core part
of Kotlin as a language.
Kotlin also has this
template expression syntax
that make it so you don't
have to mess with string
concatenation as much.
And this is a small one,
but semicolons are optional,
so one less thing to think
about when you're programming.
There are a lot
more larger features
that are kind of core to
what Kotlin is as a language.
Kotlin has coroutines, which
are these great primitives
for writing, reading,
and reasoning
about concurrent code.
It's also 100%
interoperable to Java,
so you don't have to migrate
your whole project over
in order to start using Kotlin.
You can start with just
one class or one file.
Kotlin is also
expressive and concise.
We routinely hear
from teams how nice
it is to start writing in
Kotlin because you can say more
with less code.
And last but not least,
Kotlin's trailing lambda syntax,
which you kind of just
saw an example of,
lets you create
domain-specific languages,
or DSLs, really easily.
This lets you do
things in a concise way
that you wouldn't expect from
a type-safe JVM language,
like generating markup,
configuring your build,
or really concisely configuring
routes for a web server.
So we talked about what
Kotlin is and now wanted
to dive into the
history of Kotlin
and why teams are adopting it.
The Kotlin project
was originally
created 10 years
ago, but it really
started accelerating in 2016.
That's when 1.0 was
released and Android
announced official
support for it in 2017.
It grew really
quickly on Android,
which is one of the
largest Java language
platforms in the world.
And by 2019, more than
50% of the top 1,000 apps
on the Play Store
were using Kotlin.
And this year
Kotlin pulled ahead
to become the number
two language on the JVM,
ahead of Scala.
It's routinely reported as
the number one fastest growing
language in the
world, and we'll look
at a couple of concrete
examples of that.
So here's just a sampling of
companies that are using Kotlin
in production today, and
you'll notice that many of them
are mobile-first companies.
A lot of them started
using Kotlin on Android,
but many are growing it on
the server side as well.
The main takeaway
here is that Kotlin
has had a lot of time
to incubate and grow
through usage in some of
these flagship companies.
It's production ready.
And at Google, we're also
going all in on Kotlin.
It's our preferred language for
Android app development now.
And here's an example of
just some of the results
the Google Home
app team saw when
moving 100% of their new
feature development to Kotlin.
They saw a 33% reduction in
the null pointer exceptions
they saw from their app.
And when they moved classes
from Java to Kotlin,
they saw on average a 30%
reduction in the lines of code.
Additionally, we're
also seeing a lot
of teams internally
within Google adopt
Kotlin on the server side now.
So metrics teams, a number
of our logging teams,
platform teams for a number
of our largest products
have just started
introducing Kotlin.
And the internal
server framework
that powers Google applications
is migrating to Kotlin as well.
Lastly, I wanted to bring
the concision point to life.
This is one of the
reasons that people
seem to enjoy programming
in Kotlin the most.
So what you see here
is a plain old Java
object that you might notice
has a lot of boilerplate code--
PersonJava.
So it has getters, setters,
an equals method, hash code,
and a lot more.
It might look familiar to you.
Now, here's the exact
same object in Kotlin,
and you might be wondering what
happened to all the extra code.
Kotlin language
features take care
of generating the
necessary bytecode for you,
so those getters, setters,
hash code are still there.
Only you don't have to worry
about handwriting them.
Instead, you can spend time
being creative, implementing
new features that your
customers actually need,
and not worrying about
writing hundreds of lines
of boilerplate.
So now I'll hand
things over to James
to talk about how Kotlin can
work with some of the server
tools, frameworks, and APIs
that you might already be using.
JAMES WARD: So Kotlin
works great on a server
and on the cloud.
It works great on Google
Cloud, so if you're
using just raw compute
instances or you're
using Kubernetes or Cloud Run
or any of the other compute
platforms, Kotlin is awesome
because it runs on the JVM,
it interoperates
with Java, and a lot
of the modern
Java-based frameworks
are now supporting
Kotlin as well.
So, for example, Spring Boot
has added great Kotlin support.
There's a new framework
called Micronaut that
also has great Kotlin support.
There's support now
in Kotlin for gRPC,
and then there's a [? really ?]
[? new ?] project called
Cloudstate.
And so we'll go
over some of these,
but let's start
with Spring Boot.
Spring Boot is the most
popular enterprise framework,
and usually people are
using that with Java.
But now with the
new Kotlin support,
you can use Kotlin
with Spring Boot,
and it feels really natural.
You still get the
annotation-based injection
and all the other great
parts of Spring Boot.
But then you, as well as that,
get all the features of Kotlin,
including coroutines,
null safety,
and all that great stuff.
So let's actually
take a look at a demo.
Let's look at some code and
deploy a Spring Boot Kotlin
application on the cloud.
Let's take a look at a little
demo of a Spring Boot Kotlin
application and run
it in the cloud.
I'm on a repo here on GitHub--
jamesward and then
springboot-kotlin-reactive-demo.
And before we take
a look at the code,
let's go get this thing
deploying up on the cloud.
One way to do that is to
hit this Run on Google Cloud
button, so I hit that.
And now it's going
to say, are you sure?
I'm going to confirm, and it's
now launching Cloud Shell.
Cloud Shell is a VM in the
cloud with a SSH-like web
interface to it.
And this just allows us
to automate a few steps,
so we don't have
to do much typing.
So lets clone that Git repo
we were just looking at.
And then it's asking me which
project do I want to use.
I will use jw-demo.
It's going to enable
Cloud Run on that project,
and then it's going to ask me
which region I want to use.
I'll use us-central1.
And now it will go
through some steps
to deploy this application
from that source code
up onto Google Cloud.
So we'll check back
in on this in a second
because it's going to take
a minute or so to do that.
While it's doing that,
we can take a look
at a little bit of
stuff in this project.
First, there is the pom.xml.
This should be familiar.
This is for the Maven build.
Nothing too exciting in here
other than the Kotlin stuff,
Spring Boot stuff.
And you'll see that
I'm using WebFlux
so that we get a non-blocking
reactive HTTP server
for this Spring Boot project.
So nothing Kotlin yet,
but let's go take a look
at the Kotlin source code.
This is in the demo application
and really basic Spring Boot
application here.
So I've got my demo
application class, which
has my router in it,
and we'll take a look
at that method in a second.
I'm using some
Kotlin features here,
like a data class
called Release,
and then I have a
function main that
starts up my demo application.
So what this application
does-- very simple.
It's going to make an HTTP
request out to the GitHub API
to fetch the tags
for Kotlin releases.
And this is using
the web client,
which is also a non-blocking
WebFlux-based HTTP client.
So because of
Kotlin coroutines--
and a great feature of Kotlin--
we have a suspend function.
So even though this is a
non-blocking async call,
we're able to make it look
like it's just sequential.
So we're going to get
our releases, which
are going deserialize
into our list of release.
And what I was trying to do with
this application is just get
the actual releases, not
any milestone releases.
So we see some other
features of Kotlin here.
One is that the question
mark or the Elvis operator
used for dealing with
nullability because maybe
my releases were null.
I didn't have any
releases, or I wasn't
able to fetch the releases.
Then I can do that question
mark [? so it would ?] chain
on operations when
it's not null,
so then I can do a filter
with a nice little function
syntax there to filter out
anything that doesn't contain
a dash or that--
filter out all the things
that contain a dash.
And then I'm going to, again,
use the nice nullability
support in Kotlin,
get the firstOrNull,
and if it's not
null, then I'm going
to get the name of that release.
And then if any of those
operations in that chain
were null, then I'm going to
provide a default of not found.
So some really nice features
of Kotlin here in a Spring Boot
application.
Let's check back in on Cloud
Shell and see how we're doing.
So it looks like it's
all up and running.
So it did the mvn
package jib:build.
Jib is a nice Maven
or Gradle plugin
that can create container
images, Docker container
images.
And so it did that for us,
created our Docker container
image, and stored it up on
the Google Container Registry.
And then once we get
our container image
for our application up on the
Google Container Registry,
we can do our gcloud run deploy
and deploy this application
from that container image, so
with some parameters there.
But our application
was deployed,
and now it's up and running,
so let's go check it out here
on the cloud and make sure
that we see the latest
Kotlin release here.
So it's now starting
up that application,
making that non-blocking
request out to the GitHub API,
getting back that list,
getting the first one
after applying the
filter, and there is
our latest release of Kotlin.
So there's our really basic
Spring Boot Kotlin application
running up on Google Cloud using
Cloud Run, which is serverless.
And I'll show you
just real quickly some
of the features of Cloud Run.
We can click through into
the UI for Cloud Run, where
we can also do deployments
and create new revisions
and check the logs
and see metrics
and all that kind of stuff.
So here we have
our application up
and running where we can come
in and check out the revisions.
We can see that
there was one that
was deployed two minutes
ago and then check out
the logs for the application,
see it all up and running,
and see details and deploy new
revisions and do great things.
So nice thing about Cloud
Run is it's serverless,
so that means there's
no servers to maintain.
And it scales up and
down based on our demand.
So that is our Spring Boot
Kotlin application running up
on Google Cloud.
OK.
So that was a example of
using Spring Boot and Kotlin
on the cloud, but now
let's talk about gRPC.
gRPC allows us to
use protocol buffers
to define our data objects.
So we have a language agnostic
way to define something
like a greeter service
and then the messages
that that service can handle.
So this allows us to use
gRPC with any language.
It's protocol agnostic,
support strong typing.
It'll generate the objects
around those services
and messages, and
then it'll also
generate the clients
and service objects
to interact with those services
from a client to a server.
And best of all, it's super fast
because it's built on HTTP/2.
So we now support Kotlin with
gRPC through a project called
gRPC Kotlin.
So gRPC Kotlin, what we do is we
generate Kotlin idiomatic stubs
based on the Java stubs
that are generated
by the Java gRPC project.
So this supports coroutines
for doing async stuff.
It supports the Kotlin
flow API for doing
stream-based processing.
So that means that your services
can take a stream as an input
and/or return a
stream as an output,
and then you use the standard
flow API to interact with it.
There's plugins for doing
gRPC Kotlin for both Gradle
and Maven.
And, of course, it's
available in Maven Central,
so easy to get.
So let's take a look at a demo
for gRPC Kotlin and its stream
support and running on
the cloud with Cloud Run.
Now let's take a look
at an example that
uses gRPC and Kotlin.
You can find this
on GitHub under
the GoogleCloudPlatform/kotlin
samples and then run and then
grpc-hello-world-streaming.
There's a few different
examples in here.
We're going to look
at the streaming one.
And if you want to deploy
this up on Cloud Run,
you can just click this
Run on Google Cloud button,
and that will deploy it.
And we'll let Cloud
Shell start up
and then go take a look
at the source code.
So in the source
code for this sample,
let's first take a
look at the proto file.
This is the protocol
buffer definition
that defines a service
called Greeter,
and rpc on that service
called SayHelloStream.
It takes a HelloRequest, and it
returns a stream of HelloReply.
And then you can see our
HelloRequest and HelloReply
message objects down below.
So the gRPC Kotlin
project will then
generate the classes to interact
with the service for Kotlin,
and let's go take a
look at how we actually
use those generated stubs.
Here we have the
HelloWorldServer,
and we'll start up the server.
All that the server
does is implement what
happens on that sayHelloStream.
So you can see it
takes a HelloRequest,
and it returns a
flow of HelloReply
because our gRPC returned
that stream of HelloReply.
Flow in Kotlin is a
way to do a stream
with non-blocking
back pressure and all
that kind of good stuff.
So we're going to
emit a HelloReply,
and what we're going
to do in that reply
is create a new HelloReply
from the builder
and set the message to hello
and then whatever name came
in the request.
So we're just going to
omit that every second.
So that's our server
implementation.
Nothing very fancy there.
Then let's go take a look
at the client that uses--
connects to that server.
So in this case, we're going
to use the generated stubs
for this gRPC service,
and we're going
to have a function
in here called
greet, which is
going to take a name.
And then it's going to do
this runBlocking, where
it's going to assemble
a HelloRequest
and set the name to
whatever was passed in.
And then it's going to call
the stub SayHelloStream,
give it that request,
and this returns a flow.
So that's the Kotlin flow.
And then we're going to
do a .collect on here with
a function that
takes the response.
And in this case, we're
just going to print out
the message that was passed in.
Now, down here we can
see our main method
where we start up the
client, and you'll
see that when we
start up the client,
we're going to-- if
there is an argument,
we're going to use it, an
argument to the program.
If not, we're going to just pass
in world, so you'll see what
actually then gets passed in.
We set the name to the
name that was there.
Then if we look
back at our server,
it sets the message
that it's going
to emit every second
to hello comma and then
the name that was passed in.
So let's go back over
into the Cloud Shell.
And I'm actually just going
to cancel out of this.
I'm not going to go
through the deployment
because we don't need to.
It's already deployed.
And now I'm going to run
the client against my server
that's up and
running on Cloud Run.
So what I'm doing is I'm taking
the Docker container that
was created if we had followed
through with that process
and let it run to
create the Docker
container from that source code,
but I've already done that.
And then it's going to run the
HelloWorldClientKt application,
and then it's going
to pass an argument
to the application, which
is the server to connect to.
And if you'll remember,
we take that argument,
and we output it after
hello every second.
So let's now run that
Docker container.
It's going to go grab that from
the Google Container Registry
and download that to Cloud
Shell to my local Docker daemon
there, and so that'll take a
second to pull all that down.
And once that's
pulled down, it'll
start up the Docker container,
run the HelloWorldClient,
and then connect it to
our running on Cloud Run.
And, remember, Cloud
Run is serverless,
so it scales down when
there aren't any requests
and then automatically
scales back up as needed.
And you'll see that it's
started up that gRPC server,
and now it's outputting every
second hello with that argument
that was passed in.
So there we go.
That's our Kotlin
gRPC application
running on Cloud Run and
doing a streaming response.
So that was gRPC Kotlin.
Now let's take a look
at a new project called
Cloudstate, which has great
Kotlin support as well.
Cloudstate was created to
support distributed programming
through some new architectural
patterns called event
sourcing, CQRS, and CRDTs.
And I'm not going to go into all
the details of what those are,
but if you want to do really
high-scale distributed
computing, then you may
need architectural patterns
that support that.
So the new Cloudstate
project is open source
and has a cloud service
built on Google Cloud
that we can use
with Kotlin to build
these massive-scale
applications.
Let's take a look at a little
demo of Cloudstate with Kotlin.
Let's take a look at a
Cloudstate Kotlin example
that uses the Lightbend
Cloudstate service to run
this on the cloud.
And you can find the
source code on GitHub--
jamesward/cloudstate
sample fraud.
OK.
First, let's take
a look at the code.
So with Cloudstate,
we use protobufs
to model the messages
that we're going to send
and then the rpc operations
that will be performed.
So we have a transaction with
a timestamp amount, location,
and description.
And then we have a user
transaction that associates
that with a
cloudstate.entity_key,
which allows us to do the
partition of the messages.
And that also gives
us the ability
to scale this thing up and
down horizontally based
on what's happening
to the messages
as they're being partitioned.
OK.
And then we have a way to
add the transaction, a user
transaction, and
get transactions.
Let's take a look at
the ActivityEntity,
and this is where the logic
for handling those messages
happens.
So we've got an
EventSourcedEntity,
and then you can see
there's a constructor
argument with a user ID,
which is our partitioning key.
So that's how we're able
to partition this data.
In this class, we
have our transactions,
which is our MutableList.
And so whenever we get
transaction messages coming in,
then we're going to be able
to add them to this list
so that we have our accumulated
state here in this entity.
Then we have a command handler
for addTransaction, which
takes that user transaction.
And then we also get a
command context [? right ?]
[? there. ?]
And then we can have our
logic for detecting fraud
on a transaction.
So whenever a new
transaction comes in,
we're going to use the past
data and the new transaction
to calculate the velocity.
And so there's, obviously,
lots of different ways
that we would calculate--
compute whether or
not the transaction
is potentially fraudulent.
For this simple example,
I'm just using velocity.
And if the user's velocity
goes over a max velocity,
then we're going to say
that there's possible fraud.
And in this case, we're just
going to output to the console.
But then once we have
detected the potential fraud,
we are going to emit a message
which says, OK, we've done
our handling of this message.
And then that
EventHandler will trigger.
This will go on to an event log,
which has persisted in Spanner,
in Google Cloud Spanner.
OK.
So that's the bulk of
the entity processing.
I've got a [? little ?] class
that just starts up the server,
and then I've got a
simulator class that is going
to simulate some transactions.
So let's go over
and run this now.
I already have
this up and running
on Google Cloud via the
Lightbend Cloudstate service,
but let's go start
up the simulator,
and what this will do is start
adding a bunch of transactions
to this transaction log.
And what we'll be able to--
once this starts
emitting those messages,
we'll be able to see the
messages that are being emitted
here in the console.
And then we'll go over
to Google Cloud Logging
to actually see if we
get a potential fraud.
So here we go.
We're now feeding a bunch of
transactions into that system.
We've got multiple
users, so we're
doing partitioning of
the data for that entity.
And now here in Cloud, the log
viewer in Google Cloud, now
we can see the server
messages from my entity
that's running up on Google
Cloud and Lightbend Cloudstate.
So let's go try to jump to
now and see-- there we go.
OK.
So it looks like we just
got a possible fraud alert,
and we can see the user ID,
the merchant, the amount, when
it happened, and then
the Google Map linked
to where that transaction was.
And if we let this
continue running,
we probably will see some more
potential fraud alerts coming
in as that simulator runs.
So you can see we're
feeding in tons of messages.
They're partitioned
based on user ID,
so we get the ability to
auto-scale the service
up and down.
And that's great for
something like this
where the amount of
transactions that are coming in
is going to fluctuate
throughout the day,
with probably more transactions
happening in the morning
and evening, I would
guess, and less at night.
And so great.
We can scale our service
automatically based on that.
There's a container image
that I built and deployed,
which contains my entity code.
OK.
So that's the quick
example of Cloudstate
running on the Lightbend
Cloudstate service.
So that was
Cloudstate for Kotlin.
And that's it that we
wanted to show you today.
Thanks for watching,
and we hope that you
will build Kotlin
stuff for Google Cloud,
and check out some
resources for that.
You can go to
cloud.google.com/kotlin.
And thanks so much, David,
for joining us and showing us
why we should use Kotlin.
DAVID WINER: Yeah.
Thanks, James.
We're really excited to see
what you build with Kotlin,
and hope you enjoy the
rest of Next OnAir.